[Music]
one of the most famous movie villains in
cinematic history returns with the drama
Joker Warner Brothers recorded a huge
success in 2019 which also thrilled
audiences beyond the superhero genre now
the long- awaited sequel Joker 2 fad do
finally hits the cinemas on October 3rd
2024 where we will be finally presented
with the interaction of Arthur Flack and
his lover Harley Quinn in this video you
can hear all the latest information
about the upcoming sequel Joker 2 is
likely to be one of next year's
Blockbusters the untypical production of
the cult figure already convinced
viewers and critics in the previous
movie and made it the most successful
R-rated film of all times with worldwide
box office takings of over $1 billion
originally the ton Phillips directed
character study was intended as a single
work and should not have received a
prequel however ultimately the success
and positive feedback led to the
decision to continue the story having
said that the movie is said to be
clearly different from the previous film
and will hopefully break new ground it
is already known that Joker 2 will take
place in the high security prison Arkham
Asylum to a large extent this was
designed by its founder Amadeus Arkham
as a treatment center for the mentally
ill and houses a number of unusual
criminals the first Joker movie finished
with Arthur ending up in this very
Asylum from here obvious story lines
from the comics could be picked up in
Joker 2 the story that is most likely
refers to the graphic novel mad love in
which the Joker first meets Harley Quinn
and models her into his lover this is
the story of Dr harleen quinzel Who
works as a psychiatrist at Arkham Asylum
and is supposed to treat the Joker due
to her own traumatic past harleen
quickly sees the joker as a role model
and is attracted to him the Joker takes
advantage of this for himself both start
a relationship and together they escape
from the prison Harley increasingly goes
insane herself and becomes more and more
entangled in the relationship with the
dangerous clown Harley's well-known
origin story is also reflected in the
film's title fad do translates as
Madness for two and is an expression for
a psychotic disorder in which close
people develop the same delusional ideas
of course the main role of Arthur black
Alias Joker is again portrayed by Wen
Phoenix who even won an Oscar for best
male lead actor for the last movie the
role of Harley Quinn will be performed
by none other than Lady Gaga herself we
can certainly expect a significantly
different version of the figure than the
one of Margo Robbie in the previous DC
films in addition to the two main actors
several other well-known names have
already been confirmed for the cast for
instance we will see Harry Potter star
and character actor Brendan gleon get
out actress Katherine Keener is also
part of the cast as well as Maze Runner
actor Jacob laughland and Harry who has
so far been seen mainly in TV shows zazi
Bates returns for part two as Arthur's
former neighbor Sophie we're curious to
see if she primarily plays a role in The
Joker's imagination as she did in the
first movie Orie might actually pay her
a visit after breaking out of the Asylum
like its Forerunner Joker 2 is part of
the so-called DC El World these are
films and series that have no direct
reference to the DCU that is why DC
characters are embodied by other actors
than in the official main series here in
addition to the two Joker films these DC
else worlds also include the Batman
films by Matt Reeves and the upcoming
sequel Constantine 2 Tod Phillips will
once again take a seat in the director's
chair and oversee the project Peter
saffran and James Gunn will be the
producers as in part one the music will
be composed by Icelandic composer hildor
guus noad deer in an interview with
comicbook.com she commented on the film
and revealed that there would be a lot
of music in it with this comment she
picked up on the controversial news that
there will be various musical passages
in the second Joker movie this news
aroused resentment among many fans as
one does not necessarily associate the
serious and under Earth drama with
typical Hollywood musical films we are
more than curious to see how this will
actually be implemented in the film in
the end typical Disney scenes in which
the Joker sings about his feelings are
probably not to be expected at the
beginning of April 2023 director Todd
Phillips announced that filming had been
completed he finalized this with the
words that's a wrap on his Instagram
Channel and also posted two new pictures
of his main characters already while
filming photos repeatedly reached the
public on which Lady Gaga could be seen
as Harley Quinn furthermore a video made
the rounds in which she kissed an
enraged woman on the mouth dressed as
Harley now that the film is officially
in post-production it shouldn't be too
long before you're presented with more
images or a first teaser
trailer according to current information
the theatrical release of Joker 2 fad do
is still scheduled for October 3rd 2024
since the film has already been shot the
actor strike that is currently taking
place should not cause any major
problems here what do you think does
Joker 2 have the chance to continue the
success and quality of the previous film
or do you immediately think of a big
failure when you hear the word musical
tell us what you think of the comment
[Music]
m